yeah like I always knew I was a star and
was just a case of how long it would
take for everybody else to realize that
even when he was a broke 16 year old
skinny kid with a stupid haircut he's
always had that same belief so I joined
a college Boxing Club and the trader
said you're okay but I'll take you to a
real boxing club and he took me to the
Fitzroy lodged in in South Lamba and you
know 21 I was probably 13 14 stone and
there wasn't really any one big enough
to spar with me so they put me in with
this kid a 16 year old kid skinny stupid
pineapple haircut stupid vest that was
tied together in the middle for some
reason and actually thought I'll take it
easy with this kid this isn't really a
fair fight
and it was the classic you know bull
method or situational cow method or
situation and every time I throw a punch
he would just appear here somehow and
hit me twice here and twice here
sometimes he's just stand there and I
couldn't get anywhere near him and he
could have hurt me but he didn't he just
showed me that he can land punches
whenever he wants and how everyone's and
it was David that was the first time I
ever actually met David I've moved Tommy
selves with kids and I was at 11
I've always got up soon well I won't be
fair Scooby tie off when I was 12 and he
gave me the trophy and the pool and I
was my milady in a while there's Barry
because at the time in being an
international boxing England box McGee
be so locked up some fun I always I've
done since that day is that the
straightest person of a messy just sees
how it is he never like tries to be on
the fence he just gives his opinion and
I love that about him because you know
where you stand with Tony if he tells
you like sure the election he doesn't
say yeah I found that hilarious for you
didn't mean to be I just finished funny
because you just say today I just wanna
sorry rare these days da someone says
realism like you just say so it is not I
just found him hilarious funny those
because I'm not used to it I'm you
slightly around like people like on the
GB squad you like always on the fence
and time it everyone happy where they're
using care he was just hated about it is
it's very funny laid-back and down to
where he go while I was waiting for ya
don't know many people at his level will
go either way you're someone like me
he's just a young Keiko Murphy so so
he's really good enough sense that he
will give back honey will either help at
hand
you needed asking me a sorta for where I
came from
probably a better background than he did
in terms of opportunity I would never
dream I could have you know travel the
world hang out with his famous athletes
and writers and actors and directors and
stay in villas in Jamaica and have a
fleet of cars and and he just saw that
as his right I wrote a piece for GQ
about him years ago and the ending quote
was something like yeah look I always
knew I was a star it was just a case of
how long it would take for everybody
else to realize that you know unless
that's what he's liking that's what I've
always been like no matter no matter
what you know even when he was a broke
16 year old skinny kid with a stupid
haircut driving a beaten-up go around
London he's always had that were both
from the same area and the people talk
to us which is a bit of a rough area
gentlemen so he come from where I've
come from and he is master now he's done
very well for himself and it gives me
hope that I don't do the same I icon the
gym now watch what he does and I take
notes and I did the same trying like
obvious mentality if just business fast
I believe it's nice to go sentimental
like boxing like he if you any reason
your brain oh you doubt yourself
Oh show up in the ring I believe some
fighters or quizzes when it gets hard
near doable and I know meself face nod
never ever give up and Tony does as well
that's right only sometime says he wants
to me home to his kids cause he knows
that he a coaster that deep trenches
where it's dangerous turn I mean you
know how dangerous sports is and though
you will not quit and after that
mentoring yourself I will not quit for
non
you